[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're only gonna be mind-blown that's
how I'm gonna put it Sammy was just an
amazing ball of energy Samuel was great
he's very very passionate he's got a
massive heart he loves teaching and
seeing successful people and he's very
sore in there getting it done and let's
just get this done no matter what no
barriers let's get it done just spent
two days of your life and you know and
just come and do it and then see
different options and probably change
your thinking and just go for it the
time invested here he's going to pay you
back in the future if you listen to what
you have heard if you put the tools into
use and what you've heard into action
then it will pay you back in time and in
money if you never try coming to the
crash course you'll never know what will
change your life you could be thinking
what would have happened if I didn't go
you know ten years down the line
someone's life could have changed but
your life would still remain the same
Samuel there's a pretty outstanding job
and I think the selflessness of him
doing the course for people like myself
for free and it is for free there's no
catches or anything that behind it it is
genuinely two days of his time giving
back to everybody which is pretty
phenomenal there's zero to lose but
there's just an empowerment discourse
let alone a set of new knowledge it
genuinely is empowering you made some
great people I can't say enough the
value of what you're gonna get from here
as a potential to change your life
experience
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]